no,
how about that question that mejía with the brief
informative today is thursday june 3
new information on
unemployment applications a new report revealed that
385 thousand people applied for
benefits last week this figure
is below the previous week to those
who evade five  1,000 more filed for
unemployment just above
regular numbers The average number of people
filing for unemployment in the
state is down 20 percent
Meanwhile if you're looking for a job
El Dorado Cantina is having a
job fair tomorrow at its new
Southwest Valley location near  sunset and
durango will be from 10 to 4 in the afternoon and
interviews will be held the same day
and there are more opportunities at the las
vegas stadium to look for workers
over the age of 16 there is an event
scheduled for this Saturday from 9 in the
morning to one in the  late you are asked to
bring your resume and be prepared
for an interview more details on
the work 9 dot com page
and follow the esf  urging to get
the coronavirus vaccine there will be
several schools offering the
facer vaccine totally free today and
tomorrow Friday you can receive the first
dose between 3:30 and 5:30
in the afternoon the same clinics will
return three weeks later to give
the second dose  you can go without an appointment but
it is recommended that you make one through
the health district page now
we turn to the weather conditions
pay close attention because we have an
excessive heat warning
high temperatures are forecast 108
degrees will be a new record for the
date of  today we will have a lot of sun
for the rest of the weeks is that you take
your precautions have a nice day I
am héctor mejía and this was your brief
informative of kirchner in spanish
[Music]